I was looking at court hosen Beck's
resume here and he got some negative
reviews I think people weren't quite
sure what to make of court hosing back
but he's a health and fitness expert he
says he played in the USFL he had a book
called rice cake revolution total yogurt
recipe guide bestseller of 27 I mean
they're they're 27 books he's done a lot
I know he's big into animals canine
kennel foundation I believe this is his
first national interview his cord hosen
Beck who joins us now cord thanks for
joining us and welcome to the program
thank you so much for having me what a
pleasure and a thrill to be on your show
it's just great to to take the time to
talk to you broadcaster to broadcaster
and real quick correction there Dan
it's the Rose Parade no Rose Bowl parade
okay my bad chord thank you how many
years have you covered the Rose Parade
well cattigan and myself have covered it
for 25 this is our 25th year can you
believe it since 1992 and every year
just gets better than the previous year
we really enjoy ourselves and have a
great time I'm looking at your resume
California all-state football player
well yeah I was uh I don't like to toot
my own horn but you brought it up yes I
played it at Victor Mountain College I
was a defensive end I still hold the
record for 19 sacks and then transferred
to Palmdale State where I moved to
offensive line and had a great two-year
career there a lot a lot of great
memories at Palmdale State the dragons
and then in 1995 I got the call-up to
the big leagues and I played a four
games for the New Jersey generals of the
USFL four of the greatest weeks of my
life
Chuck Fairbanks was my coach I still
consider Brian Sipe a great and dear
friend I don't get to talk to him as
much as I'd like to but Brian if you're
listening I still I still think about
you all the time
well Wayman was the USFL in business of
1995 as far as I know okay because I
remember covering okay okay all right
well then that makes a little more sense
there cord because I remember I remember
the New Jersey generals I was looking at
some of the people and people can be
rough with with the Twitter court as we
know yeah I thought they they were a
little rough on you they they thought
you were a little off-color how did you
handle the criticism look here's the
thing
you're gonna have to crack a few eggs to
make an omelet right and you're gonna
have to they're gonna have to climb a
hundred mountains before you reach the
peak and I'm not perfect I'm still a
work in progress
I'm an open book when I'm out there you
know I I shut all that out because just
guessing my worst critic is Dan cord
hosing back exactly exactly
and when I look at myself in the mirror
I'm like cord what are you gonna work on
today so there can't be a bigger critic
out there than myself and should I read
some things that that people here's the
first people who talked about it felt
like I talked about my fear of horses
too much and I have a legitimate fear of
horses you don't know the there's always
two sides to every story at the same
time I got so many people responding
thank you for talking about equine
phobia and it's a real issue out there
and I and so for as many people that
thought that maybe I spent something
about too much time talking about that
and not the parade there were just as
many people who said thank God you
addressed your fear with horses because
there's so many people out there who are
also afraid of course it's a big animals
Dan I'm right there with you cord I it's
not a charity that I'm familiar with but
I'm sure that it's it's prominent cord
hosen Beck is joining us as he was the
co-host of the Rose Parade and also a
basset hound breeder yes yes
by all 15 of my dogs here in my study
they're all sitting attentively
wondering who who Papa's talking to I've
got Franklin on my lap right now once
the dog but he's a dog you can't talk
but yeah there yeah that's my family
I'm your blast single by choice I'm not
in a current relationship even though
there is someone else that is interested
I'd love to have a cup of coffee but
right now single and but I have my
fifteen beautiful beautiful basset
hounds here do you have your stove your
MySpace page I
I'm still keeping that going yes okay
yes and are you on tinder or anything
like that
nope nope nope I'm more of a face to
face guy yeah I don't you don't know
anyone in your world do Dan in your
sphere of influence Wow
you're tight you might be too much you
might you might have too much going on
cord you're much fun you're just too
busy of a schedule well your health and
fitness expert personal trainer
best-selling author speaker basset hound
breeder television radio holy books yes
and you played in the USFL I mean that's
a lot for somebody to try to keep up
with yeah did you mention the total
yogurt recipe guide I know but I know
you did the rice cake revolution that
was my bestseller I also did the
stickers method were you nothing but
citrus for two years I just so you know
I did mention to some people I know at
ESPN you got Monday night maybe opening
with Jon Gruden out and I thought you
know what if you want to go rogue cord
hosing back could be so much you slip in
the booth on Monday Night Football okay
my agent is standing by my agent meaning
me is ready to take a call at any I mean
I would give my right you know what
host arm Monday Night Football yeah
so that would be a thrill of a lifetime
you know I haven't done commentating in
a long time since we were on the rodeo
Network mmm a long time ago Tish and I
hosted a show on the rodeo network for
two years but that would be a thrill in
SL are you kidding me
and what is cord is it short for
something
oh I thought it was cordless but English
Oh English Lord corduroy the full name
was wide rail corduroy wide with
corduroy Posen back
that's a lovebird yeah and I just it's
too much of a mouthful yeah it is so
Cora was already taken actually sad
there was already a a wide whale
corduroy hey shorten it d'accord hey
thank you for making my Rose Parade just
a little better
thank you and I was listening earlier
and there's all this talk about what the
Cleveland Browns are gonna do what did
you guys say they have something like 18
picks they have 12 they're 12 okay my
mistake you think they can find one in
the 12 you you would think so see that's
the kind of insight that you're not
going to get from any of these other
analysts on Monday Night Football you
know it dad
I live on the East Coast Court okay well
if I'm ever in the in the East Coast
frequently am don't find you we'd love
to have you on next great you know what
I would probably organized a parade just
to have court hosing back come in
anytime anywhere that's what I thought
yeah I thought but all the best to you
accord in a happy new year and once
again new year Dan and congratulations
thank you thank you we are on cloud nine
that's that's cord hosing back co-host
of the Rose Parade not the Rose Bowl
parade the Rose Parade whoo great get
that's a personality I think that's his
first national interview cord hose in
fact almost feels
you could make him into a movie
character for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]